vous regardez journal de l'afrique sur
france24 très heureux de vous retrouver
dans l'actualité du continent
aujourd'hui pape diop rebat les cartes
au sénégal une semaine après les
législatives
l'ancien maire de dakar rejoint la
coalition pouvoir macky sall retrouve
donc sa majorité à l'assemblée
explications à venir delhi mme ndao
le kenya attend toujours le nom de son
futur président les spéculations vont
bon train mais les résultats officiels
ne sont pas tombées à la patience
s'ajoute la crainte de fraudes connu par
le passé nous serons à nairobi et puis
emmanuel sodji nous emmènera à ouidah au
bénin la biennale rend hommage à la
culture à la culture vodoun via
notamment des projets pédagogiques
macky sall n'avait besoin que d'une voie
pour retrouver sa majorité à l'assemblée
c'est désormais chose faite le député
sénégalais pape diop élu la semaine
dernière décide de rejoindre la
coalition au pouvoir
il s'est exprimé ce jeudi à dakar les
précisions des limes nda
j'ai pris un toute responsabilité la
décision de rejoindre le groupe
parlementaire qui sera mis sur pied par
la coalition présidentielle gbagbo qui a
car c'est là une déclaration de pape
diop a tenu tout à l'heure dans un un
point presse pape diop a fait partie des
trois leaders de coalition politique qui
au terme de ces élections législatives
n'avaient qu'un seul un poste de député
en rejoignant ainsi la coalition au
pouvoir bengolea quartier en fait sa
majorité à l'assemblée nationale au
terme des élections législatives du 31
juillet la coalition au pouvoir n'avait
que 82 postes de députés y avait besoin
deux postes de députés supplémentaires a
pour avoir cette majorité au parlement à
pape diop a créé une crise
institutionnelle
si l'opposition est majoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale c'est sa
principale explication sur le fait qu'il
ait rejoint la coalition au pouvoir
48 heures que les bureaux de vote au
kenya ont fermé et toujours pas de
résultats à la télévision les
estimations s'enchaînent mais seuls les
chiffres de la commission électorale
feront foi elle a commencé le
dépouillement et a jusqu'à lundi pour se
prononcer une chose est sûre pour le
poste de président le duel entre raïla
odinga william ruto s'annonce très
serrée bastien renouil état à nairobi
pour france 24
les médias kényans ont effectué leur
propre décompte de cette élection
présidentielle grâce au formulaire mis à
leur disposition par la commission
électorale mais il ne les compte pas
tous dans le même ordre ce qui permet
l'annoncé de résultats complètement
différent entre les différents médias
est ce qui perturbe particulièrement de
très nombreux kenyans comme ces femmes
que nous avons rencontrées dans un bar
de la capitale
manama cité et pour dhumal par exemple
sur citizen télé on voit que routot est
en tête et quand on zappe sur une autre
chaîne ils disent que c'est raila odinga
qui est en tête donc on ne comprend rien
certaines personnes m'ont conseillé de
ne pas suivre ces résultats car ils ne
sont pas fiables et ils m'ont dit que je
devrais attendre ceux de la commission
électorale
eyed peas toute la journée les
différents médias kényans ont donné des
scores extrêmement proches aux deux
principaux candidats raila odinga et
william ruto et si parfois le
vice-président actuel william ruto a été
donné en tête par certains médias et
bien ici dans le bidonville de kibera
long des bastions de raila odinga
cela n'inquiète pas particulièrement ses
supporters - tokyo jusqu'à présent je
fais confiance à ces résultats et en
tant que membre du parti de raïla odinga
j'ai envie d'y croire je suis certain
qu'on va l'emporter je n'ai aucun doute
je me trouve maintenant au centre
national de décompte des voix c'est ici
que seront associés les résultats de
cette élection présidentielle les
officiers de la commission électorale
présente autour de ces tables sont en
train d'effectuer le décompte des voix
et les partis politiques ont dépêché des
observateurs afin de s'assurer qu'il n'y
ait pas de tricherie je peux vous dire
que ces partis politiques considèrent
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin des médias pour
savoir le résultat de cette élection
hitchcock partis politiques je peux vous
l'assurer à l'heure qu'il est a déjà
compté tous les bulletins qui ont été
téléchargées en ligne et tout le monde
sait qui a gagné si vous aviez assez de
personnel vous aussi vous connaîtriez
les chiffres ce que je sais c'est que
nous menons mais il n'ya pas que lui des
as de william ruto qui proclame sa
victoire azimi olhao modja de raila
odinga aussi dit avoir gagné cette
élection mais aucun des deux parties
pour l'instant nous célèbre cette
victoire ils attendent tous les deux la
proclamation de la commission électorale
qui pourrait prendre jusqu'à sept jours
après le scrutin
anthony blinken a donc terminé sa visite
en afrique par le rwanda le chef de la
diplomatie américaine s'est entretenu
avec le président paul kagame plusieurs
dossiers épineux ont été abordés
question des droits de l'homme et le
contentieux avec la rd congo voisine
laurent d'acheter hier
en pleine nuit anthony blinken arrive à
kigali dans ses bagages le secrétaire
d'état américains ramènent de la
république démocratique du congo des
inquiétudes
selon kinshasa ray un rapport de l'onu
les autorités rwandaises soutiendrait
des groupes armés rebelles dans l'est du
congo un sujet qu anthony blinken a pu
aborder avec le président paul kagame
tout soutien de groupes armés dans l'est
de la rdc mettant en danger les
communautés locales et la stabilité de
la région et chaque pays de la région ne
respecter l'intégrité territoriale des
autres
les etats-unis ont le même message pour
tous les pays de la région
paul kagamé dément fermement ces
accusations et se dit prêt à discuter
directement avec le président congolais
pour apaiser les tensions le secrétaire
d'état américain a aussi abordé la
question des droits de l'homme au rwanda
régulièrement dénoncées par les ong
internationales
le cas de paul rousset sabbagh inna est
le plus cité ce héros du rwanda purge
une peine de 25 ans de prison
en ce qui concerne le gouvernement du
rwanda paul russe et sa bague inna est
un citoyen rwandais il a été arrêté jugé
et reconnu coupable
nous demandons à nos partenaires de
respecter la souveraineté du rwanda ses
lois et ses institutions
tout change avec sa visite au rwanda
anthony blinken termine son déplacement
en afrique il s'est d'abord rendu en
afrique du sud puis en république
démocratique du congo pour augmenter
l'engagement américain en afrique
subsaharienne et contrer ainsi l'
influence de la russie et de la chine
dans la région
ce jeudi a débuté un deuil national de
trois jours au mali après l attaque de
tessit survenu dimanche dans la zone des
trois frontières attac a attribué à des
djihadistes
le bilan de 42 soldats et de quatre
civils tués a été confirmée trente sept
terroristes sont mortes
sa dissolution n'a pas entamé sa
détermination en guinée le fn décès
maintient la manifestation prévue le 17
août le front national pour la défense
de la constitution s'oppose aux
militaires au pouvoir depuis des mois
il est à l'initiative des rassemblements
organisés fin juillet malgré leur
interdiction cinq personnes y sont
mortes le collectif voire la décision de
la junte de le dissoudre une tentative
d'intimidation
le pouvoir militaire contesté aussi au
soudan comme chaque semaine des milliers
de personnes ont défilé dans les rues de
khartoum elle énonce le coup d'état du
25 octobre elles veulent une transition
civile et de meilleures conditions de
vie laurent d'acheter car
près de 10 mois après le coup d'état la
contestation ne faiblit pas au soudan
ils étaient des milliers à descendre
dans les rues de khartoum ce jeudi pour
s'opposer à la dernière proposition des
autorités de transition
on ne se sent pas du tout représentée
par cette initiative
il n'y a que par la rue que nous
obtiendrons le stif
l'initiative portée le mois dernier par
un influent chef religieux soufi prévoit
la tenue d'une conférence nationale
chargée d'établir une feuille de route
pour sortir de la transition
accueillie favorablement par le
gouvernement du général abdel fattah al
bourhane la proposition a suscité la
colère de l'opposition qui affirme ne
pas avoir été invité à cette conférence
elle dénonce une manoeuvre politique
cherchant à exclure les comités
révolutionnaires des négociations à
venir
cette initiative détourner les gens du
travail accompli par les comités de
résistance ces derniers mois
toute initiative qui n'est pas dirigée
par les communautés ne peut aboutir
depuis le coup d'état du mois d'octobre
les manifestations contre le pouvoir
militaire s'enchaînent et se succèdent
au soudan malgré une violente répression
qui a déjà fait plus de 100 morts en
plus des revendications politiques
nombre de soudanais dénonce l'inertie
des autorités face à une économie en
chute libre
le sujet fait débat au sein de la
société ivoirienne la libération des
prisonniers politiques la plupart ont
été arrêtés lors des crises qu'a
traversée la côte d'ivoire le week-end
dernier je vous le rappelle le président
ouattara a gracié son prédécesseur et
ancien rival laurent gbagbo des détenus
condamnés pour des infractions mineures
ont aussi été libérés reportage de notre
correspondant samuel bernard
dans sa maison familiale de yopougon à
abidjan giuliana ton mur autour de son
mari et depuis maintenant dix ont honte
et 1012 ce membre des forces spéciales
au service du président laurent gbagbo
est arrêté alors qu'alassane ouattara
est au pouvoir il est incarcéré depuis
ça rappelait les dix ans quand marié
temps présents
se sont épris revoir son mari un espoir
que julianna n'abandonne pas
de nombreux ivoiriens attendent le
dernier geste de leur président sur la
question des prisonniers politiques
nombreux auraient déjà été libérés mais
selon l'opposition
une centaine d'entre eux sont encore
détenus les ivoiriens veulent à la
réconciliation on veut finir avec la
parenthèse fermée définitivement la
parenthèse le début d'une donc tout ce
qui rappelle celle là doit pouvoir fini
et que nous puissions avancer dans notre
position c'est que nous souhaitons ou
démon blond la libération de ces
prisonniers amnistiés pour tourner la
page des années de crise une méthode
initiée en 2018 lorsque le président
amnistie 800 personnes accusés ou
inculpés de crimes liés à la crise de
2010 2011 une méthode qui fait malgré
tout débat en côte d'ivoire en français
peut il ya une crise depuis 2002 on sait
que la crise post-électorale a il ya eu
au moins 3000 morts il faut qu'ils les
injustices et la
loin d'un politique et du politique pour
l'heure impossible de savoir si les
libérations vont avoir lieu
un litre de gasoil à plus d'un euro au
niger la hausse du prix des carburants
décidée le 1er août commence à se faire
sentir sur les transporteurs et les
consommateurs les nigériens vivent en
moyenne avec moins de deux euros par
jour un accord a été signé entre
gouvernement syndicats et associations
le but limiter l'impact de cette
augmentation sur l'économie
correspondance de gérard
une réaction très rapide du gouvernement
nigérien qui avait certainement déjà
prévu plusieurs mesures de compensation
bien avant de permettre cette hausse du
prix du gasoil sur son sol une hausse
qui n'avait pas été annoncée au
préalable et qui a pris à revers
plusieurs milliers de travailleurs ici
au niger et qu'ils avaient même empêché
plusieurs transporteurs de reprendre la
route alors qu'ils étaient en transit à
niamey faute de moyens pour acheter du
carburant la surprise donc qui a été
justifiée par le gouvernement par une
crainte de la spéculation toutes les
fois que vous devez abouti à des postes
et que l'information est connue avant il
y à une ingénierie une industrie de la
spéculation qui peut se mettre en place
et qui peut créer une pénurie de
laquelle vous ne sortirez pas
heureusement c'est donc pour protéger
notre économie de ces spéculateurs
éventuelles cette mesure a été prise et
conduite de cette manière les mesures
prises elles sont censées faire
équilibre avec cette bouche du prime et
le gasoil lui va rester à plus d'un euro
le litre au niger il est trop tôt et les
accords fournis par les syndicats et le
gouvernement sont encore trop floues
pour savoir si oui ou non les nigériens
vont pouvoir supporter une hausse
générale des prix liée à cette
augmentation du coût de ce carburant
prendre toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour contrôler les augmentations
fantaisistes des prix de services de
transport au niger et des produits de
consommation
courante
les nigériens subissent déjà depuis le
début de l'année 2022 une hausse du coût
de la vie due à l'augmentation des coûts
du transport c'est donc
nouveau coup dur pour une nation enclavé
qui importe une large partie de ces
marchandises dans des convois menacés
par l'insécurité
tantôt mais également par la hausse des
prix du carburant dans plusieurs pays de
transit un coup dur également pour les
plus précaires car le salaire moyen au
niger lui reste autour de 50 euros
nous vous parlions mardi d'une boisson
censée faire blanchir la peau qui
faisait débat au cameroun notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux un sujet qui vous a
d'ailleurs beaucoup réagir 1 depuis sa
diffusion son utilisation était dénoncée
notamment par des médecins en raison de
ses conséquences néfastes pour la santé
à l'origine de ce breuvage la députée
nuran foster que vous venez de voir et
que vous voyez encore qui avait fondé
son entreprise de cosmétiques elle
annonce sur son compte facebook fermé
toutes ses agences sur le territoire
camerounais la faute selon elle à ce
qu'elle appelle une cabale politico
médiatique contrairement à ce qui est
affirmé ne s'agit pas là d'une victoire
de france24 notre équipe a rempli sa
mission de journaliste en donnant dans
son reportage la parole à toutes les
personnes concernées
deuxième épisode de notre série
consacrée à la biennale de ouidah au
bénin les arts et les cultures vaudou
marqueurs de l'identité béninoise sont
mises à l'honneur cérémonies rituelles
concerts défilés de mode rythme la
programmation une visite guidée signé
emmanuel ceux qui
au sein du palais royal là où siège le
chef suprême du vaudou c'est ici que se
déroulent toutes les festivités de la
biennale c'est une première édition
organisée par laboratorio art
contemporain pour en parler avec moi la
directrice de la biennale lily ou bien
est ce que voulait dire au monde que le
vaudou n'est pas simplement qu'une
religion il est très important pour nous
on devait présenter le vos dons dans
toute sa complexité
le vaudois est un système de pensée
c'est toute une civilisation
avec forcément un acte religieux mais le
vaudois aussi portait d'une esthétique
très particulier et cette esthétique
elle n'est pas seulement ancré au bénin
ainsi à ouidah aussi le continent
africain elle a eu l'occasion des
sommets de nouvelles esthétiques dans
les amériques dans les antilles
françaises aux états unis en haïti à
cuba et c'est tous ses fils source et
africains ou afro descendants que nous
convoquons ici dans cet espace qui est
sacré pour les vaudouisants du monde
entier pour se regarder face en face et
construire une nouvelle façon de vivre
ensemble et pourquoi pas choisi une
place vous double pour cette biennale
c'est vraiment original aouidat nous
intéresse particulièrement parce que il
y a la plus grande représentativité des
éléments du panthéon vos dons à ouidah
l'on retrouve toutes les communautés
qu'est ce qui lie tous ces artistes qui
sont prévues pendant la biennale
pour nous les principes du vos dons sont
les principes de vie universelle la
curiosité de l'autre le respect de
l'altérité le respect de la nature
l'écologie la protection de
l'environnement voilà ce sont des
engagements simple auquel la nature nous
appellent avec les crises et les enjeux
qui s'opposent qui s'imposent à notre
génération c'est aussi le lieu de
célébrer c'est l'explosion esthétique et
cette complexité esthétique que le
vaudou porte en lui que ce soit gravé
les aviser la musique les performances
les ahora toi la danse les artistes
viennent de partout du bénin bien sûr
mais aussi d'haïti de cuba ou d'europe
très attendu l'artiste prêtre haïtien
air-sol josé une véritable bête de scène
et puis aussi le groupe béninois beam
est en national un groupe qui redonne au
rock et au rap ses origines vaudou ouf
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui merci de
nous avoir suivis et retrouver le
journal de l'afrique aussi sur france 24
points comme et nos réseaux sociaux
prenez soin de vous à demain
[Musique]